I'm very excited to announce that Megan
and myself had a baby boy early this
morning
a very healthy boy mother and baby are
doing incredibly well has been the most
amazing experience I can ever possibly
imagine how any woman does what they do
is beyond comprehension but we're both
absolutely thrilled and so grateful to
all the love and support for everybody
out there from everybody out there it's
been it's been amazing so I just wanted
to share this with everybody still think
about names on it's the babies a little
bit overdue so we've had a little bit
time to think about it but some yeah
we're still that's that's but that's the
next fit but for us I think we'll be
seeing you guys in probably two days
time as planned as I found me to be able
to share it with you guys and so one can
see the baby I haven't been in many
births this is definitely my first birth
beer is amazing absolutely incredible
and as I said I'm so incredibly proud of
my wife and as every father and parent
we'd ever say you know your your babies
absolutely amazing but this little thing
is is absolutely to die for
so I'm just over the moon thank you very
much guys